I'm joined today by Jackie Schechter who
is a former CNN and current TV
correspondent now serving as the
editor-in-chief of investigate Russia
org the name of a website which will be
very interesting to some in our audience
and will be very angering to some in our
audience so I mean big picture what what
are you seeing now as the big storyline
in the Russia investigation because
there's so many angles there's the
so-called collusion which is a very big
umbrella term there's possible crimes
that might have been committed in the
attempts to suppress whatever took place
financial crimes all of these different
lines I mean how are you thinking of it
big picture well I think it's important
to note the way that we're thinking
about a big picture is this is a major
national security issue and I want to
make that point very clear right this
isn't a Republican issue or a democratic
issue it's not a partisan issue it's
about the national security of the
United States and if we had had tanks on
the streets if we had bombs dropped out
of the United States there would be a
rallying cry but because this is
happening in cyberspace because it's
happening in a less tangible form we're
not seeing the same rallying cry and the
same pressure basically on leadership on
the President to do something so the way
that we're looking at this now from our
perspective is you've got the
intelligence community saying
unanimously yes Russia attacked us
during the last election they're not
showing any signs of slowing down
they're going to do it again in 18 and
20 and we need leadership at the top to
do something about it and and the
president frankly is not so what we're
looking at it from is do something right
implement sanctions or you know come out
and publicly say something it needs to
be in support of what the intelligence
community is advocating but there's been
no direction to do that and that that's
where I think we're most hung up right
now do you think that part of the reason
that it's not sort of being taken more
as a red alert as you're sort of
alluding to is because of the online
nature of some of the initial hacking
because there's lots of Nod online stuff
that took place right I mean the meeting
and Trump Tower
that was certainly set up via
between the Russian lawyer and manna for
and Donald Trump jr. etc it was an
in-person meeting to talk about dirt on
Hillary and the possible intimated quid
pro quo of easing Russian sanctions like
you you would think that that would be
real enough for a lot of people and yet
you still have contingents of the left
and right that sort of refused to admit
anything's going on here yeah I think
it's hard to admit that you were
influenced by an outside source I think
that's part of the problem right is
there's a lot of people who are
supporters of the president who say you
know I wasn't influenced by Russian
propaganda the Russians didn't change my
vote they didn't affect my vote and so I
think there becomes an issue with trying
to understand how that serve tisha Slee
happened and how people don't want to
admit that they've made a mistake or
they've been influenced in some way I
think it takes a very strong person to
say yes I was influenced and I feel bad
about that or I go to rectify that in
some way and so I think what happens is
because all of that influencing happen
in a very subtle level we're not so
subtle but we weren't really paying
attention to and we're looking for it
then it's hard to get people engaged in
that admission and then they say okay
what do we do from it from here do with
it from here but I think it's important
to point out I just want to add this is
it there's a long history behind this
and I think what gets lost is because we
don't have a lot of time to talk about
it is why Vladimir Putin is so
interested in infiltrating our democracy
and trying to really undermine the West
and why he's so despised Hillary Clinton
so we think that if you get into history
of why this happened it's easier to
understand how to place why it was so
many years in the making and what the
impetus was behind it and why frankly
it's a very good strategy for Vladimir
Putin because it doesn't cost a lot of
money it allows him to be disruptive it
allows him to attack NATO to attack
Western democracies and the way that
brush is going to get stronger it
doesn't have the financial resources or
economic resources to do that is by
dismantling its enemies and a lot of
that I think Jackie which I've been
talking about also is sort of the
geopolitical perception of Russia around
the world and if you go back and read
that book foundations of geopolitics
from the 90s it specifically says that
the approach of Russia towards countries
the bigger West
democracies like the United States
should be to just try to sort of create
chaos make it appear as though the most
fundamental democratic institutions are
maybe not as solid as the countries in
actually doing the voting would like to
believe and that's sort of by comparison
it makes Russia appear both more stable
and sort of more of a geopolitical
authority do you think there's something
to that absolutely I mean there's a
thorat area to control in Russia and if
you remember a lot of their Putin was
trained as a KGB spy he's always gonna
be KGB and he likes to maintain power I
mean he's going into an election now
where there's no real opposition he's
got allegedly 80% approval rating but
he's got such control over the country
then there's really no opportunity for
opposition and the one man Navalny
Alexei Navalny who's really posing a
threat to that authoritarianism has been
banned from running against Putin I'm so
there is outrage and there is uprising
but it's being quashed asbestos Putin
can it thanks to the Internet we're
getting more and more information about
it but there's a whole generation of
young Russians who want democracy you
want the freedom to protest you want the
opportunity to speak freely about what
they believe is corruption in their
society and they're not able to do that
but the more that Putin and his allies
and the oleg Arts who run Russian
society are able to dismantle or at
least get the impression that they're
dismantling Western democracies the more
power they're able to consolidate it
makes me look stronger to make the u.s.
I'd love for you to address a very
specific sort of contingent of the left
and this is not the contingent of the
left that thinks there is no story
period right I'm not super interested in
really addressing that group but there's
a very specific group that says yeah
something something shady went on here
and it's not clear if it was the actual
coordination but maybe the firings and
the sort of pattern of obstruction or
this might reveal financial crimes that
may have taken place whatever but their
main criticism is it's a waste of time
for media outlets both corporate and
independent to talk about this because
there are many other important issues to
discuss where do you fall on that what
is the validity and importance of
covering the trajectory of this
investigation oh I would say we're not I
mean I think that this is really an
inherent national security issue and
part of our mission and I think should
be the media outlets mission is to
spread information because the more
educated we are the better news
consumers will be and yes there are a
bunch of issues but we can multitask as
a nation and frankly I mean I was a
registered independent for a very long
time because it was a journalist and you
were always taught that if you were a
journalist you should be registered
independence was not to give the
impression of any kind of political bias
I registered it as a Democrat once I got
into advocacy a bunch of years ago in
health care reform because I wanted to
have an impact on the primaries so I am
registered now as a Democrat and I
consider myself progressive but we can
multitask
that's the nature of our party and I
mentioned that because we've always been
a big tent party and part of the problem
I think on the left is that we have
trouble sticking to one narrative
because there are so many very issues
the rights very good at message
discipline because they have a very set
I would say a very a very narrow highway
of issues that they're concerned about
and it's pretty easy to get everybody on
message and pushing in the same
direction at the same time because we
tend to be more of a big tent party and
we're open to other people's ideas we do
get distracted and it's hard to catch
one narrative but I would advocate that
yes it's important it's important
because we may have corruption at the
highest levels of government and because
it's a major national security issue if
we continue to be influenced by foreign
powers we can easily descend into an
authoritarian regime or a kleptocracy or
you know whatever we're on the verge of
right now will continue to operate in
the shadows if we don't continue to
elevate it into the into the light as
far as the nitty-gritty of this
investigation what's your assessment
right now of who is most at risk of
indictment this is a great question you
know I am so enveloped in this day to
day I always say to people if you like
spy novels if you like CSI if you like
law and order
into this sort of like murder mystery
intrigue you should be following all of
the ins and outs of this investigation
because it's got everything I mean now
you've got poison spies in in Britain
and this isn't the first there was a
definite EC of the founder of Artie and
Putin's a media guy that seems awfully
suspicious I mean when you dig into the
details just the mystery and the
intrigue of it alone is fascinating I
think who shares in trouble I think that
there's a blurring of his financial
interests and government foreign policy
obviously manna forts have big trouble
and and I do believe that manifold is in
big trouble with some higher-ups and
other countries they think he's less
afraid of trunk than he is of the
Russian oligarchs and the Russian mob
but these are all my conjectures based
on just the information that I've read
you know megyn kelly did that long
interview with Vladimir Putin and I was
frustrated because she previewed it on
Chris Matthews and she said something
about me she baleen from her interview
they Trump's that rather prove he's got
something on chompin and I was waiting
and that interview to see what that was
yeah wasn't Jessie she didn't show
anything and that was so frustrating
because I actually have gleaned that as
well but I could have said that and I
can't say that based on anything
definitive I can only say that based on
kind of my conjecture and the amount of
research that I've done in guiding this
project um so yeah I mean I think we all
think that there's some financial stuff
there and it can go back there was an
amazing timeline that we're really
excited where we're going to co-opt it
and put it on our side it's gonna have a
new home it's the stephen harper cir
excuse me bill moyers timeline and we're
gonna absorb that into into Cir and if
you go back and you look at me trumps
connections to Russians and Russian
money goes back into the 80s we had a
Russian mobster essentially buy a bunch
of condos in Trump Tower and this this
money entanglement for him goes way way
back and and I think you know following
the money is is exhausted rhetoric at
this point I mean we just keep saying it
over and over again but I think it's
totally true last thing in the brief
time we have left Jackie could this all
just sort of evaporate like this is as
far as it's going to go the charges
we've seen indictments so far will be it
and beyond that we'll get some kind of
report that yeah there was there was non
criminal core
and that's as far as it's gonna go no
further charges or does that seem
increasingly unlikely to you love me
maybe I'm being overly optimistic but I
don't think Robert Muller is going
through all this trouble to just end
here I think he's got it
I think he's gonna gonna create an
airtight case I think our biggest
problem right now in this Congress I
mean I think what you have is a
Republican Congress that is unwilling
for whatever reason to stand up to
President Trump I think they know
there's corruption I mean people forget
in Devin Nunez who's the chairman of the
House Intelligence Committee was on the
trunk transition team right I mean he's
not carrying water because he just kind
of likes the guy like there's something
there he knows something and I think
people need to keep that in mind is is
the people who are carrying water for
the Trump administration at this point
on this particular issue and will aren't
representing the interest the American
people have an investment somewhere and
I think that that's where we need to
keep our eyes yeah which makes it even
more important as I've been saying
whether it's net neutrality or this
investigation or whatever got a vote in
November right there's no excuse at this
point not to vote it's not difficult I
mean there are there is
disenfranchisement going on
yeah but stand in line I mean we stand
in line for for less important things I
mean people really need to turn out when
we can get Trump's tax returns we can
get impeachment proceedings started like
we can get things moving but we have to
have a majority and we need to turn on
the vote do that Jackie Schechter check
out investigate Russia dot-org thanks so
much for your great work Jackie oh it's
my pleasure I'm having fun